hey guys how's it goin so I'm pretty
excited right now if you can't tell
there's a little something behind me I
am so excited because I just got a
really early birthday present it's
actually not that early cuz March 20th
is my actual birthday that when I heard
a loud back during the Nintendo
announcement of all of the new fun
things coming out that March 20th the
new super Mario amiibo and Mario Party
10 would be the launch date light bulb
went off I said guess what I'm having a
Mario Party party for my birthday my
birthday's not here but technically I'm
already celebrating because I'm so
pumped up about unboxing these amiibo
and the new Mario Party 10 I'm gonna do
a comparison of the amiibo to the snack
for there's an Evo of the game
hello pains me to open these because I
know so many of you guys are collecting
them in their full containers so with
every rip I was like oh my god someone
out there is crying so obviously you
guys do know how to tell which amiibo is
which me Super Mario amiibo have the red
base and the checkered little metallic
detail it's crazy they just they look so
much like the same person
herself Bowser is real chunky he is
hefty actually looks a lot like the
Smash Brothers amiibo he's got a little
more texture over here though his shell
is a little bit more green his skin tone
a little more yellow his hairs a little
bit more red Bowser you're looking good
you look at a little jaundiced but hey
that's not my problem here we've got
peach she's like I ain't even showing
you the bottom of my stand here I'm
super conservative a little more detail
on Smash Brothers shadi you got it
you got it bad next up we've got Yoshi's
and Super Mario Yoshi is much bigger
than Smash Brothers Yoshi his shoes are
a little more orange he's got a little
more of a turned-up tail yeah a size
comparison I'm in love with Luigi John
Leguizamo I will never forget I actually
like the Super Mario Luigi a little more
than this guy because it's just kind of
like made me uncomfortable you look me
Super Mario Luigi looks to be a little
more tan still a little more detail in
the Smash Brothers Luigi and last but
not least toad who is pretty much one of
my absolute fave
characters of all time he's just
freaking cute and there's no comparison
he is the only one toad you're just
perfect so those are the Super Mario
amiibos they'll be out on March 20th and
I'm so excited because I love amiibo so
much I love it so much that I have spent
many hours trying to perfect the perfect
PDF checklist which because I had all
kinds of crazy pre-orders I wasn't sure
where I'd ordered from so I made this to
sort of help myself I thought I would do
a little Mario Party 10 giveaway in
honor of my birthday I guess I don't
know how to do the giveaway maybe just
take a selfie of yourself with something
Mario related it could be absolutely
anything Mario or Nintendo theme and
tweet it to me at iJustine use the
hashtag IJ Mario Party and I'll be
searching those on Twitter and I'll pick
somebody and I will send it to you
directly from Amazon because I don't
like to go to the post office